et oui j'ai dit que ça vous arrive on va
faire l'interview nul on les bouge faim
pendant le jingle
est ce que vous préférez hitler ou
staline c'est très difficile hitler
certainement pas 100 aligne non plus ma
faim de deux mois je choisirais plutôt
maline d'accord parce qu'il a tué plus
de gens baffie non pas pour ça mais
parce que je crois que peut-être une
certaine époque lui certaines choses
permettant même si j'étais totalement
dénaturé alors vous devez partir de 3
ans dans un vaisseau spatial
vous avez le choix entre jean pierre
chevènement c'est l'horreur jean louis
debré à jean marie le pen
c'est abominable ouais je crois que je
pars avec jean pierre chevènement mais
avant de partir je me débrouille pour
que se crée dans le territoire de
belfort à un mouvement indépendantiste
très virulents les cours qu'il
apposerait son retour infuser coeur à
qui vous accorder le plus de
circonstances atténuantes à un vieux qui
se tape des petites ou un jeune qui
table sur des vieilles n'en ai aucune
circonstance atténuante soit possible
sauf qu'à trop plein ça n'a pas eu à le
parler vrai qu'en témoignent ces zones
touchées à des choses qui sont sacrées
chez nous les enfants et les vieillards
chez nous aussi ça crée un vous
inquiétez pas un ski vous gênerait le
plus ça serait d'être surpris dans un
jeu de l'esprit palam d'être surpris au
lit avec un make way deux filles avec un
mec me paraît difficile pour le moment
ça peut changer mon fin pour le moment
il y 6 me gênerait le plus vous c'est
d'être surpris au lit avec un mec avec
deux filles avec un mec et vous aussi
compte tenu de ce qu'ils évitent cela ce
serait ça obligerait les deux surprises
au lit avec un mec vous aimeriez avoir
un nez supplémentaires un acte
supplémentaire un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe supplémentaires à l'oeil
derrière derrière c'est normal c'est la
corse
on est bloqué tous les deux dans une
bergerie dans la montagne vous et moi il
ya la police française tout autour qui
nous assiège je me la raison parce que
j'suis pas parce qu'on est des hommes a
pris le maquis en et des raies c'est un
jeu de l'esprit un jeu meurent de froid
s'il fait froid dawa je meurs de froid
une bergerie de haute montagne
oui je meurs de froid il est obligé de
me manger vous commencez par quoi on ne
peut pas arriver s'assurer de bloquer
dans une bergerie avec moi et qu'on est
susceptible d'être encerclés par la
police sur un tunnel et voilà
cioni
merci